well some employees at the va hospital
aren't happy with how their employer is
handling kovid so
they're taking matters into their own
hands it is a story the i-team's vanessa
murphy first broke and she's live in
front of the v-a hospital joining us
with more
brian two employees here have died of
covid19 and a source says
26 currently have the virus and a total
of 137
have had it since march still union
members say it is difficult
for employees to get tested here at
their workplace
robert olson is the chief steward of
local afge 1224.
employees can get tested only if they
show signs or
symptoms but as we've been reporting the
virus can spread by people who have
no signs or symptoms union leaders like
olsen say
covid19 testing should be more
accessible to employees
so the union set up its own today and
over the next two mornings
olson says it can help protect employees
and
patients they've earned the right to the
medical care
and that and not just the medical care
but good quality medical care
and that's what we deserve as vets is
that good quality medical care
and if i can do any part where i make
sure we've got people healthy and taken
care of then i'm going to do it
olson says they're offering the testing
through an outside agency and will do it
again
in december before christmas and you may
remember this is where southern nevada's
first
known covid 19 patient was hospitalized
back in march
since then as we reported the union and
management here
have butt heads multiple times over
covet 19 and whether
employees are protected enough now a
spokesman for the va tells me they
follow cdc guidelines here anyone
including employees
have to be screened before they enter he
also says their safety practices
have limited the infection rate of
employees to less
than one percent he tells me the va here
has provided care to more than 750
covid 19 patients reporting live vanessa
murphy
8 news now